ah
[Música]
francia y sol vio el grupo generación
cité a un grupúsculo de extrema derecha
anti islám y antimusulmanes en enero
trataron de evitar la llegada de
extranjeros en el paso fronterizo de los
pirineos con drones de vigilancia aunque
fue en vano el gobierno considera que se
trata de una milicia que incita al odio
al racismo ya la discriminación así
justificó su decisión una decisión
similar que ya ha tomado hacia
organizaciones islamistas en el país en
negación de un tuiteo nacional 2012 dice
tener unos 2.800 miembros y cuenta con
el apoyo de reagrupamiento nacional el
partido ultra francés que salió en a su
defensa diciendo que este decreto era
una violación a su libertad de expresión
reacción anti te hacía grandes rasgos el
mismo discurso político que por año se
ha pregonado el partido de marginal open
teniendo a los musulmanes y a los
extranjeros como una amenaza para el
país el grupo dijo que va a apelar la
decisión ante el consejo de estado
[Música]
según trascendió en medios alemanes la
agencia doméstica de inteligencia del
país empezará a supervisar de manera
sistemática al partido alternativa para
alemania bajo sospecha de extremismo ya
algunas partes del partido como las
juventudes fuera la más radical habían
estado bajo vigilancia de las
autoridades de inteligencia pero esta
medida le permite a la agencia doméstica
ir mucho más allá para determinar su
alternativa para alemania representa un
peligro para el orden constitucional de
alemania es una noticia muy importante y
muy controversial no solamente porque a
efe de un partido muy joven descrito
como de ultraderecha representas de las
elecciones de 2017 la principal fuerza
de oposición en el parlamento del país
sino también porque 2021 es un súper año
electoral en alemania con varios
comicios regionales y por supuesto las
elecciones federales de septiembre a efe
de rechazó esa supervisión considera que
puede afectar la políticamente en este
año electoral y la calificó de
escandalosa
[Música]
extremistas domésticos de derecha fueron
responsables del 70 por ciento de los
planes y los ataques terroristas en eeuu
durante el 2020 así lo revela el centro
de estrategia y estudios internacionales
basado en washington según erc durbin
que es el director del comité judicial
del senado esto se debe en parte porque
durante los últimos cuatro años del ex
presidente de donald trump este minimizó
la amenaza de los supremacistas blancos
durbin dice que además hay que ser
claros en que los supremacistas blancos
son la amenaza terrorista más grande que
afronta eeuu y que los republicanos y
los demócratas tienen que trabajar
juntos para acabar con esta amenaza en
este momento el fbi y adelanta más de
2.000 investigaciones de terrorismo
doméstico y después de los ataques del 6
de enero ha arrestado a cerca de 280
personas y ha acusado a otras 300
[Música]